>> IT IS GREAT HOPE THAT I WANT
TO DISCUSS TONIGHT.
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
THE LATEST ESCALATION IN
VIOLENCE BETWEEN ISRAEL AND
PALESTINIANS.
THE CEASE-FIRE DOES SEEM TO BE
HOLDING FOR THE TIME BEING.
WE HAVE BEEN HERE BEFORE IN 2009
AND 2014.
WAR TEMPORARY TRUCE AND WAR
AGAIN.
CLEARLY IT'S THOSE UNDERLYING
CAUSES THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED TO
ACHIEVE A LONG LASTING VIABLE
PIECE FOR THE BENEFIT OF BOTH
PALESTINIANS AND ISRAELIS
EQUALLY.
IT'S A TERM THE U.S. AND THE
SECRETARY OF STATE HAS BEEN
USING LIBERALLY ON HIS TOUR
THROUGH THE REGION.
YOUR THOUGHTS.
>> HOW IMPORTANT IS WHAT WE
BUILD WITH THE UAE.
WE ARE BUILDING A NEW MODEL.
WHAT WE SAW IN GAZA IS THE
PEOPLE OF TODAY FIGHTING THE
WARS OF YESTERDAY AGAINST PEACE.
MISSILES -- USING MISSILES
AGAINST CIVILIANS TO SOLVE
PROBLEMS OR CREATE PROBLEMS.
WHAT WE SEE HERE IS A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT MODEL.
WE SPOKE ABOUT TOLERANCE.
WE SPOKE ABOUT BUILDING
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN PEOPLE,
ABOUT EDUCATION FOR PEACE.
LEARNING ABOUT EACH OTHERS, OUR
HISTORY, OUR SHARED HISTORY.
YOU COME HERE, YOU SEE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE.
WHAT WE TRY TO BUILD AND WHAT WE
ARE DOING HERE IS BUILDING THE
EXACT OPPOSITE OF WHAT WE SEE,
WHAT WE SAW IN GAZA.
GAZA FIRING ROCKETS AT ISRAEL.
>> RIGHT.
HAMAS TOLD ISRAEL THAT IT WAS
THE RECENT VIOLENCE, THE THREAT
OF FORCED EXPULSIONS OF
PALESTINIANS FROM THEIR HOME.
ISRAELI POLICE RAIDING THE
MOSQUE DURING THE HOLY MONTH OF
RAMADAN.
THAT WAS THE SPOT FOR THEIR
LATEST VOLLEY OF ROCKETS INTO
ISRAEL.
WHAT I WANT TO DISCUSS IS THE
UAE'S STATEMENT THAT WAS
RELEASED URGE ISRAELI
AUTHORITIES TO QUOTE, ASSUME
THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES IN LINE
WITH INTERNATIONAL LAW TO
PROVIDE NECESSARY PROTECTION TO
PALESTINIAN CIVILIAN RIGHTS TO
PRACTICE THEIR RELIGION AND
PREVENT PRACTICES THAT VIOLATE
THE SANCTITY OF THE HOLY MOSQUE
AND THE UAE CALLING ON ISRAEL TO
PRESERVE THE HISTORICAL IDENTITY
OF OCCUPIED JERUSALEM.
THE UAE ONE OF A NUMBER OF
COUNTRIES THAT HAVE NORMALIZED
R
RELATIONS WITH ISRAEL AND HAVE
DIRECT LINES OF COMMUNICATION
WITH ISZ RAEL.
WHAT WAS THE MESSAGE, LOCALLY,
SIR?
>> IT WAS CLEAR.
I THINK WHAT THE MESSAGE WAS
VERY CLEAR MISSILES, ROCKETS
WON'T SOLVE ANY PROBLEM.
I THINK THE MESSAGE IS TO SIT
DOWN, TO RECOGNIZE ISRAEL, TO
NORMALIZE RELATIONS WITH ISRAEL.
I THINK THE MESSAGE IS CLEAR.
PEACE AND NORMALIZATION AS A WAY
TO SOLVE PROBLEMS.
>> ENABLE US TO CONTINUE TO
STAND BY THE PALESTINIAN PEOPLE
AND REALIZE THEIR HOPES FOR AN
INDEPENDENT STATE.
THE UAE HAS NOT PLAYED A LEAD
ROLE IN MEDIATING THE CURRENT
CEASE-FIRE AS WE UNDERSTAND IT.
FROM SOURCES, I DO UNDERSTAND
THERE'S BEEN SIGNIFICANT
DISCUSSIONS BEHIND THE SCENES.
WHEN WE CONSIDER JERUSALEM AND
THE ISSUE OF PALESTINIAN RIGHTS,
ARE YOU WORRIED THAT THIS RECENT
ESCALATION COULD FURTHER SLOW
THE PACE OF NORMALIZATION AND
THE BENEFITS OF THE ABRAHAM
ACCORDS AT THIS POINT?
>> I THINK THE LESSON FROM THE
RECENT ESCALATION IS QUITE THE
OPPOSITE.
WE HAVE TO FURTHER ENLANCE THE
RELATIONSHIPS.
WE HAVE TO FURTHER PROMOTE AND
PROGRESS IN OUR RELATIONSHIPS
BECAUSE, AGAIN, WHAT WE SAW HERE
AND WHAT IS REPRESENTED IS
DEPARTURE FROM YESTERDAY.
DEPARTURE FROM THE ROUNDS OF
VIOLENCE.
DEPARTURE FROM EVERYTHING THAT
WE KNEW SO FAR INTO A NEW MODEL
AND THE MORE WE DO IT AND THE
MORE WE SHOW OTHERS IN THE
REGION, LOOK WAT WHAT WE ARE
DOING.
LOOK AT THE FRUITS OF PEACE.
LOOK WHAT IT BRINGS US HERE.
THE MORE THEY SAY TO THEMSELVES,
WELL, WHY NOT US.
I THINK THIS IS THE MESSAGE.
THIS IS THE MESSAGE THEY ARE
BROADCASTING TO THE REGION.
I THINK AND I HOPE THE REGION
WILL LISTEN.
>> IT'S CLEAR THAT THE UAE'S
POSITION IS VERY MUCH IN TUNE
WITH SO MUCH OF WHAT WE HEAR
AROUND THIS REGION WITH REGARD
THE ISSUES OF JERUSALEM AND THE
ISSUES OF PALESTINIAN RIGHTS.
AS MUCH AS WE UNDERSTAND THIS
WAS A DECISION, A SOVEREIGN
DECISION BY THE UAE TO ENTER
S
INTO NORMALIZED RELATIONS WITH
ISRAEL ECONOMICALLY AND ON A
BUSINESS BASIS FOR THIS COUNTRY.
THEIR POSITION IS CLEAR ON THE
RIGHTS FOR PALESTINIAN.
I ASK YOU AGAIN, ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT UNLESS THERE'S A
CHANGE IN THE APPROACH BY
ISRAELIS THAT NORMALIZATION AND
ITS BENEFITS WILL SLOW HERE?
>> I CAN'T SEE INTO THE FUTURE.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PALESTINIAN APPROACH, ABOUT
HAMAS APPROACH.
THIS IS WHAT CONCERNS ME.
AS ABOUT ISRAEL, AS FAR AS WE
CAN SEE SO FAR, THEY ARE
PROGRESSING.
>> LET'S BE QUITE CLEAR, HAMAS
DOES NOT CONTROL JERUSALEM.
ISRAEL DOES.
ITS CHANGES THERE THAT ARE
NEEDED.
THOSE ARE UNDERLYING CAUSES.
THE YOU SUPPORT A CHANGE?
DO YOU SUPPORT EQUALITY OF
RIGHTS FOR ISRAELIS AND
PALESTINIANS GOING FORWARD?
>> YOU KNOW, YOU ASKED ME BEFORE
ABOUT FREEDOM OF RELIGION.
IT'S NOT JUST FOR ONE.
IT'S FOR ALL.
JEWS HAVE RIGHTS AS WELL AS MUSE
L
-- MUSLIMS AND CHRISTIANS AND
ROCKS FROM THE TEMPLE MOUND AS
THEY ARE PRAYING, WORSHIPPING.
FREEDOM OF RELIGION, FREEDOM OF
WORSHIP GOES AROUND.
IT'S FOR ALL.
WHAT I'M CONCERNED ABOUT AND
WHAT WORRIES ME IS I WANT
FREEDOM.
THERE WON'T BE ANY CHANGE TO THE
STATUS QUO.
IT STANDS FOR EVERYBODY.
JEWS BEEN PRAYING IN JERUSALEM.
JEWS WILL VISIT THE TEMPLE
MOUNT.
IT'S THEIR RIGHT AS MUCH AS IT
IS FOR EVERYBODY ELSE.
>> IT'S A CHANGE TO THE STATUS
QUO THAT IS SOUGHT BY
PALESTINIANS.
IT'S A CHANGE TO THE STATUS QUO
WHICH IS SOUGHT BY PALESTINIANS.
>> I DON'T THINK IT IS.
>> LET'S JUST PURSUE THIS LINE
OF INKWQUIRY BECAUSE I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN YOUR RESPONSE TO
THIS.
THERE'S BEEN A WILL THE OF NOISE
FROM PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS IN
THE U.S. CONGRESS.
I SPOKE TO ONE OF THEM RECENTLY
WHO WROTE A LETTER TO SECRETARY
BLINKEN, URGING HIM TO STOP THE
HOME EXPEULSIONS AND THE
VIOLENCE.
HAVE A LISTEN.
>> OUR RECOMMENDS DATION, STOP
COMMITTING THESE ATROCITIES.
IF YOU WANT TO LIVE SIDE BY SIDE
WITH THE PALESTINIANS, DO IT.
STOP TPICKING FIGHTS.
THE CYCLE OF VIOLENCE IS THE
SAME EVERY TIME.
SETTLERS COME IN, STEAL LANDS
AND HOMES AND IT GETS UGLY.
HAMAS INSERTS ITSELF SEPARATELY
IN RESPONSE.
IF I WERE THE ISRAELI
GOVERNMENT, HOW ABOUT STOPPING
THE CYCLE.
>> SHE DESCRIBED ISRAEL'S
GOVERNMENT AS COMMITTING HUMAN
RIGHTS VIOLATIONS.
I JUST WANT TO PUT THIS TO YOU.
SHOULD NOTHING CHANGE AND SHOULD
THE UNDERLYING CAUSES OF THE
PALESTINIAN STRUGGLE NOT BE
ADDRESSED.
DO YOU WORRY ABOUT A SEA CHANGE
IN SUPPORT FOR ISRAEL FROM
WASHINGTON?
SUPPORT THAT ISRAEL HAS ALWAYS
RELIED ON.
>> I SAW A HUGE DIFFERENCE WE
SAW HERE YEARS AGO.
I WAS BORN IN ISRAEL.
MY FATHER WAS BORN IN ISRAEL.
I'M SIXTH GENERATION ISRAELI.
PRETEXT AND EXCUSES FOR VIOLENCE
ARE IN NO SHORTAGE.
120 YEARS AGO, 1921, IT WAS A
WHOLE DAY OF PRAYING IN THE
WESTERN WORLD.
THAT WAS THE REASON.
OUR EYES TURN TO THE FUTURE.
WE WANT TO SEE A CESSATION OF
VIOLENCE.EXCUSE.
WE HAVE SEEN NO CONDEMNATION,
WIDE CONDEMNATION FOR THAT.
I THINK THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD
FOCUS ABOUT.
THIS IS WHAT WE SHOULD FOCUS ON.
>> IT IS REALLY --
>> RIGHTS, STATUS QUO.
FREEDOM OF WORSHIP AND PRAYING
FREEDOM OF LICENSE IS TO ALL
SIDES.
>> I'M REALLY PLEASED YOU JOINED
ME AT THE FIST HOLOCAUST
MEMORIAL EXHIBITION EVER TO BE
HELD UNTIL THIS MIDDLE EAST
REGION.
WE DO THANK Y